alors tout le monde ici en studio on se
tourne vers la caméra 68 on dit bonjour
à la planète en direct du studio 93 avec
les dom et demander les deux traductions
le bout du nez et de main toutes les
extrémités participent à cette joie de
vous recevoir aujourd'hui en ce vendredi
saint ici nous sommes en direct de
montréal du studio 93 donc et nous avons
eu nos équipiers régulier et il s'agit
de leonardo jimmy nos jours c'est un de
nos lois de m grâce à lui nous avons
l'occasion de vous parler sinon moi ce
sera une discussion ici même la 2 1 et
puis il manque on va l'avoir plus tard à
l'émission dans quelques instants je
pense elle sera sous forme pré
enregistré ok sur vidéo mais cette
extension est ce qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui
il s'agit de marie marie claude qui est
marie claude simard qui notre remettre
du côté français mais c'est vendredi
saint ici au canada puis aussi quelque
part dans quelques autres pays dans le
monde
elle est en congé voilà et on a aussi
ici en studio le webmestre de la section
arabe de radio canada international
zoubair jazy bonjour aux ordres de
stéphane alors on lui a lancé
l'invitation de venir aujourd'hui c'est
pas moi c'est lui ça s'est fait à la
dernière minute raymond des marteaux qui
devait être avec nous sommes s'occupe
d'une enfant malade à la maison
ok nous on est tous pour le travail le
travail à la maison
et puis la famille a partout alors on
lui dit laisse à la maison
profites-en alors zoubair vous et vous
n'avez pas d'idée comment ça fonctionne
cette émission aucune idée il sait pas
donc on va parler dit juger riz préparé
on hésite en fait pas tout est prêt pour
toi voici le premier jeu c'est une série
et à travers le jeu qu'on apprend à
découvrir le canada qu'on leur fait
découvrir aux autres à l'étranger
d'accord on vous propose lui aussi le
droit de participer c'est la vidéo en
cinq images d'accord et ce en 30
secondes cinq images vous devez
déterminer quel est le thème aujourd'hui
de l'émission ça circule on regarde vous
y allez un dès que vous avez pensé avoir
la bonne réponse vous commettez vous y
aller d'une réponse si vous avez si vous
pensez avoir la réponse ou vous risquez
de gagner un prix de participation l'art
ça commence bien pas en 2d l'art au
monde
j'ai aucune et non plus c'est un peu de
pub de cast est notre affaire de la
diversité rallye oui oui oui oui vous
vous réchauffer continuer ok la jeunesse
drouet on pourra voir me dire ça serait
le même thème remarquer et ça c'est m
mieux vivre ensemble commun moi j'étais
pas loin comme je suis pratiquement donc
bravo félicitations pour ce que je
pourrais y aller ben ça va venir plus
loin les missions les jeunes vient
priver déjà gagné quelque chose
d'ailleurs j'ai oublié de vous dire il
ya deux semaines a fait une émission
spéciale sur le sucre d'érable et vous
n'avez pas emporté le prix de
participation vous étiez également
absents ok il y en a tant c'est mardi
j'ai oublié de la portée mais c'est
ainsi du sud d'érable ils appellent ça
une canette au québec hockey et 540
mille litres de super g en bray embrun
brute embrayant de répandre et je
connais c'est tout mais c'est
merveilleux
donc ça va être très très important
aujourd'hui de participer à notre jeu
dakar la grosse boule on l'appelle comme
ça maintenant d'abus deux semaines on
l'a changé de titre à ça c'était autre
chose où ça change toutes les semaines
nos formules les lumières sont encore
trop trop élevés ou et attendez on va
tamiser la faire c'est l'ambiance après
tout qui compte
on vaut plus rien alors c'est le jeu de
la grosse boule ya trois jeux de la
grosse boule à chaque émission
si la première manche vous pour 20
points d'accord d'accord voici la
question porte le multiculturalisme
canadien politique que prône qui prend
ici au canada la coexistence de
différentes cultures c'est bien connu
les canadiens c'est bien connu aussi à
l'international cette population qu'ont
les canadiens par rapport au
multiculturalisme
je vous pose la question êtes vous prêts
elle veut bien assis en quelle année at
on discute et pour la première fois
sérieusement d'une politique d'une loi
sur le multiculturalisme en quelle année
six raids dans les années soixante dix
avec le père trudeau mais je devrais pas
dire exactement 73 74 peut-être je me
lance comme ça qu'à vous dit le père
turdo vous faites allusion au père
duffy ce temps juste avec ses sens et
bien sûr des lot de pierres dans les
années donc 70 73 74 mois 77 70 disait
mieux oui quand même s'est un peu plus
loin quoi mais là je pense que c'est
ouvert qu'est la bonne réponse donc 20
points de participation en alliant
dernière il est tellement brillant il
brille tout seul c'est vrai nous auriez
dit 1960 je leur ai accordé parce que
c'est vraiment ce moment là qu'on
commence à formuler ok l'énoncé où le
mot fallait de l'hybride et en 71
attendez voir 71 c'est le grand fédéral
adopte sa première politique sur le
multiculturalisme et en 1973 on a créé
le ministère du culte du but 6e du sel à
dire un petit coup de stress mais je
pense que tout le monde a compris on est
prêts pour notre entrevue cette semaine
sur skype il s'agit pas d'une invité
mystère puisque la moitié de la planète
la reconnaîtra immédiatement
nous vous présentons aujourd'hui les
céistes icab est ici au canada rachida
azdouz qui est psychologue spécialiste
des relations interculturelles pas
multiculturelle mais interculturel
transference j'imagine et elle vient
nous présenter son nouveau livre qui à
un titre qui va vraiment ça va nous ça
va brasser là ça va brasser tout le
monde comment dites nous quel est ce
titre wild où il part il part de quelque
chose note est quelque chose qui était
pas botté par vous vouliez c'est quand
même pas du venait mais on abcès fallait
crever quelque chose rachid
oui en fait le bonjour tout le monde à
bord à quai et moi aussi je veux du
chocolat donc le titre de mon essai
c'est le vivre ensemble n'est pas en
reste bouche comme son nom l'indiqué on
se gargarise beaucoup avec cette
expression là pas d'ailleurs pas
seulement ici chez nous au québec et au
canada mais partout en europe et
ailleurs même dans des pays émergents
zoubair vous contredirai pas
et donc je voulais un petit peu prendre
à bras le corps ce concept là non pas
avec la prétention d'en donner une
définition figée et scientifique
d'ailleurs je me dégage assez rapidement
de toute prétention scientifique parce
que c'est un essai donc c'est un point
de vue subjectif mais ce n'est pas un
point de vie frivole parce que c'est
quand même le point de vue d'une
observatrice s'est dit l'actrice de la
scène acteur culturel donc je suis
depuis 20 ans plus de 25 ans maintenant
mais c'est un essai et je prends cette
ce cette expression la vivre ensemble et
je les retourne dans tous les sens je la
déshabille cheval décortique pour faire
ressortir les différentes conceptions et
les différentes définitions parfois
contradictoires qui sous tendent cette
même expression donc comme on ne parle
pas tous de la même chose il va de soi
que ça se termine en foire d'empoigné
oui écoutez avant d'en arriver au cas
précis avant d'assassiner tout le monde
on va présenter des images de ce nouveau
livre pour que les gens une image là ça
aide à mieux comprendre en je pense et
on va voir aussi notre webmestre du côté
français avant qu'elles soient en
vacances
marie claude qui a tourné cette petite
vidéo pour nous la vidéo numéro 2
présentation du livre de rachida qui
vous allez voir donc si l'on cherche et
ce en librairie ce sera facile à repérer
ces rouges avec la belle photos de
rachida et ensuite on ajouté on a ajouté
des images du bureau à radio canada
international des gens qui consultent le
livre qui le livre ou qui le livre on
sable à dire nous on l'a lu un il ya
raymond des marteaux qu'il a lui gelé
lui donc vous a fait vous en faites pas
on sait de quoi y est question
aujourd'hui
alors voilà c'est une scène amusante on
voit jamais ça des gens au travail à
radio-canada et à radio canada
international par deux mois et on voit
ici
marie claude sénécal qui elle feuillette
le livre a bien sûr et puis lui brûle
plaisir ya aussi une autre collègue
d'accession aux espagnols vous allez
voir à l'arrière qui a beaucoup de
plaisir pas grand chose à faire
et voilà très drôle une scène de la vie
quotidienne
maintenant pour la scène de la vie
quotidienne au québec qu'on va se
retourner vers rachid à rachida vous
disiez que vous aviez pas le point de
vue d'un spécialiste mais quand même
vous êtes psychologue vous avez je pense
vous en vous regardez la société on va
le dire québécoise avec l'oeil du
docteur qui dia qui a un problème il ya
une maladie il ya une ça ne fonctionne
pas et c'est peut-être vraiment
récemment consent rencontre et pas
seulement au québec mais ailleurs dans
le monde que ça devient évident mais à
quel moment vous avez ça vous commencez
à vous dire les gens veulent vraiment
peut-être pas vivre ensemble et je vous
êtes posé la question est ce qu'on veut
vraiment vivre ensemble
oui en fait je dis pas c'est pas un
point de vue de spécialistes parce que
je me positionne quand même comme
spécialistes parce que c'est mon champ
d'expertisé les relations
interculturelles mais je dis que c'est
pas c'est pas un livre scientifique
donc c'est pas aimé ça reste quand même
académique le bon donc j'ai commencé à
me poser la question à partir de ma
propre expérience comme comme analyste
et comme pédagogue surtout c'est qu'à
partir du moment où j'ai pris acte de
l'impasse dans laquelle elle est plongée
depuis longtemps déjà et ceux qui
n'aiment pas ce qui ne fait que se donne
à fond on voit pas l'issue
c'est la polarisation du débat sur le
vivre ensemble et c'est dans ce sens là
que je me pose la question avant de
continuer à polémiquer sur le comment
vivre ensemble c'est à dire quel modèle
privilégié le multi l'inter
l'assimilationnisme il faut peut-être
s'arrêter il se posait la question avons
nous réellement envie de vivre ensemble
et là c'est peut-être un peu mon biais
de psychologues parce que je pars
toujours de l'individu je prends
l'exemple du couple je dirais une couple
peut très bien entamé une thérapie de
couple mais s'il est des deux n'a pas
envie de continuer la vie en commun et
lanthane une thérapie de couples que
pour 1 mais l'autre a accepté que le
couple est fini il faut arrêter là et il
faut que le terrain peu de vous mettre
dehors et vous disent 'vous devriez
peut-être aller voir un avocat ou un
juge mais je ne peux rien pour vous
alors c'est un peu ce qui arrive dans le
débat le débat y prit polarisé il est
pris en otage par l'extrême gauche et
l'extrême droite
et je renvoie dos à dos les deux
postures les deux positions parce que
les deux sont dans des dérives et des
excès qui disent effectivement le refus
de vivre ensemble et ce qui est pervers
sait que ça se fait au nom du vivre
ensemble
donnez moi l'exemple parce que là ça
commence comme ça le livre par des
exemples vous êtes invités à des débats
vous vous apercevez que s'agit en fait
de faux débat on veut faire semblant
d'avoir des débats mais au fond c'est
parce qu'on veut c'est parce qu'on
cherche c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
cherche et d'ailleurs je relate
plusieurs expériences que j'ai moi-même
vécu soit comme panélistes donc comme
experts invités soit comme modératrice
de situation je me suis retrouvé à
modérer un débat qui n'en était pas un
parce que tous les panélistes défendez
le même point de vue et le public était
conquis donc c'était plutôt la star
academy je dois dire que la véritable
débat sur le vivre ensemble et encore et
encore la star academy il ya des gens
qui défendent un point de vue par un
candidat au cas d'autre vie que sa photo
donc c'est un des exemples que je relate
l'autre exemple c'est les contradictions
c'est à dire de vouloir revendiquer pour
soi le droit à toutes les différences
mais de le nier à l'autre denier à
l'autre le droit de revendiquer aussi sa
spécificité c'est tout oui c'est tout
cet autre ça peut être aussi
l'accueillant la société d'accueil à
laquelle parfois dans notre désir de
défendre un point très minoritaire est
présumé nra blondieau ont dit à l'autre
mais toi tu es toi tu es déjà dominant
toutes ces dirais-je tous ces éclairages
et tous ses angles que je sens
délégitimer aucun membre
le seul point de vue que je délégitime
c'est le point de vue violent mais
haineux mais les autres points de vie
faut les écouter il faut les entend
j'adore votre façon de présenter ces
situations parce que vous démolir des
milices et tous les cas vous voulez vous
déconstruisent et la faire pour nous
montrer à tous que peu importe nos
opinions parce que c'est pas eu c'est
pas l'opinion que vous condamnez c'est
la façon d'arriver à l'opinion ou de
battre maintenant de quoi se protéger
on a préparé des petites vidéos des
petites surprises mais pour moi aussi ce
sera des surprises parce que je me
souviens plus de quoi il s'agit c'est
pas grave vous allez voir on va
découvrir ce numéro 3 cette série de vos
écrits de votre livre et ça nous amène à
une réflexion
ça prend toujours 7 secondes avant qu'on
arrive au but c'est que c'est plus long
que voilà on finit par te voir vous la
voyez on finit par perdre de vue le sens
même du débat le débat se transforme en
objet de combat c'est ce que vous avez
écrit
vous vous reconnaissez j'espère et puis
il fait pas si on ajoute une autre
citation non mais c'est bien je ce que
je ce que je remarque c'est que vous
dites
on a tous une responsabilité ici à
essayer d'avoir une vraie conversation
avec celui que lequel on n'est pas
d'accord mais vous passez en revue les
délais les différents scénarios où on
pourrait assumer une plus grande
responsabilité
les médias 1 la famille l'éducation
et puis vous avez aussi un discours sur
ou des opinions par rapport à ceux qui
disent représenter les les personnes
minoritaires les fameux directeurs
directrices d'organisation ils sont
arrivés à un moment donné ils ont saisi
l'occasion et puis la boit en dix ans
plus tard on subit encore l'opinion
enfin jeu mais je n'ai pas vu dans votre
livre
quoi quoi que ce soit de rassurant parce
que je me trompe
non pas du tout d'abord oui
vous parlez des leaders autoproclamés
que je que je que je condamne parce que
il participe au bruit ambiant sans
nécessairement ans rires de propositions
oui
la dimension rassurant elle est dans lé
talent d'humour avec lequel j'ai choisi
d'aborder tout ça parce qu'il ya deux
choses très importantes
jean par un choix très conscient je ne
me place pas au dessus de la mêlée c'est
à dire que quand je dénonce la
polarisation
je dénonce ma propre lâcheté en tant que
personnes qui participent au débat
public
la lâcheté des fois de ne pas dire
certaines choses je dénonce ma propre
auto censure ne pas dire certaines
choses pour ne pas être récupéré par un
camp ou par l'autre ne passe d'être
récupéré par les xénophobes et l'extrême
droite ne pas être récupéré par la
droite religieuse
donc je me place tout de suite dedans
comme une actrice pas seulement une
observatrice
mais aussi une actrice qui est assez
propre lâcheté et qui par son silence
des fois contribuer à la colorisation
la deuxième chose c'est vous dites est
ce que expire quelque chose de restera
donc n'apporte pas de réponse mais je
rassure dans le sens où je dis il ya
beaucoup de bruit en citant sénèque
il faut il faut séparer les choses d du
bruit qu'elles font il ya beaucoup de
bruit autour de ce débat mais le bruit
il est surtout en haut chez les leaders
autoproclamés parce que c'est leur fond
de commerce
mais ça va mal mais c'est donc et les
politiciens parce que la question
identitaire est devenue un enjeu
électoral
mais sur le terrain dans la vraie vie ça
va plutôt bien et là je pars du québec
et du canada je ne parle pas de l'europe
ça va relativement bien mais sans non
plus nier les problèmes avec des
problèmes et des incompatibilités
il ya des gars de la crispation
identitaire de part et d'autre autant
chez les accueillants que j'ai les
accueillis mais je pense que mon
optimisme il est plutôt là de dire tu
entends qu il y a encore des relations
entre les gens tant qu'on n'a pas encore
de ghettos parce qu'on peut pas parler à
propos on peut pas à proprement parler
de ghettos au québec il y aquelques
concentration ethnique ici et là on n'a
pas omis loin du scénario à la française
donc je pense que l'optimisme il est là
et
et dans dans la part du mariage mixte
par exemple un moment donné dans les
enfants de mariages mixtes ne peuvent
pas détester leur père ou leur mère ils
vont être obligés de les concilier ces
identités là et je suis pas du tout dans
la logique bisounours on s'aime on
s'embrasse tout va bien au contraire ce
que je dis c'est que vivre ensemble
c'est aussi prendre à bras le corps les
conflits les nommés ne pas léser les
excuser sous prétexte que et c'est dans
ce sens là que pour faire aussi le
multiculturalisme qui prétend que
l'éloge de la différence suffit à tout
régler mais il ya ici c'est très fort
écoutez suberbe ce que vous connaissez
pas la formule va falloir vous expliquez
vous avez droit de poser des questions à
l'invité de la semaine
ouais et je pense que vous êtes tout à
fait bien placé pour le faire
malheureusement je n'ai pas encore lu
votre livre mais je suis vraiment j'ai
hâte de le lire mais j'ai une question
comme ça qui me vient rapidement
commandé construire
cette polarisation sais pas comment vous
voyez même si vous condamnez votre
lâcheté mais malgré que si tu me
l'acheter c'est pas une lâcheté que vous
vouliez ne s'est pas assumer mais quand
même c'est pas on arrive parfois dans
des situations où on peut pas carrément
se mouiller comme on dit soit pour des
raisons professionnelles soit pour des
raisons
il dira à ce que c'est vraiment ça voilà
peine carrément de ce2 ce2 de caraman de
dire le fond de notre pensée
comment être plus ou moins efficaces
pour déconstruire en tant que des
intellectuels mais en tant que citoyen
lenteur oui merci beaucoup c'est pas la
question je sens sa discrétion venez
vous d'europe ont battu la tunisie
tunisie bon alors donc le la façon dont
je procède pour déconstruire moi je suis
aussi je j'enseigne donc chaude d'abord
avant a vanté une pédagogue
donc ce que je fais c'est que je sous
forme de dialogues jeu je n'invente un
dialogue entre les deux camps en
permettant à chacun des deux et parfois
c'est moi l'autre camp c'est moi c'est
moi la paix d'abord devant un de mes
étudiants au wind mes étudiantes qui me
dit des choses qui sont parfois très
dures parfois très raciste ou parfois au
contraire très anti raciste et je
réponds donc c'est de permettre aux deux
parce que dans la vraie vie ça se passe
pas comme ça dans la vraie vie macciana
qui parle et qui dit des choses qu'on
n'a pas envie d'entendre
on le bayonne pour le bailleur est donc
là j'essaie d'enlever le bâillon et à
travers ses dialogues de permettre aux
deux positions de s'exprimer sans être
interrompu donc ça permet en même temps
de dire regardez quand vous laisser les
gens parler bd fois une nuance eux mêmes
leurs propres propos et des fois quand
les propos sont carrément polarisée et
qui a aucune rencontre possible
ça permet aux gens qui vont me lire de
se voir dans le miroir et de dire voilà
ce que ça donne quand vous monologuer
chacun de votre côté
arc bouté sur une posture qui naquit dit
le vivre ensemble mais qui en même temps
l'an l'empêchent ben voilà ce que ça
donne
le miroir grossissant de votre
polarisation meurent là ce que ça donne
c'est dans ce sens
là que je le dis quand à quant à la
lâcheté je perds de l'acheter je parle
aussi d'autres raisons qui peuvent nous
amener à nous taire c'est des fois
justement se tait c'est la meilleure
solution
parce que ça il ne faut pas ajouter aux
bruits ambiants
parce que ce soit ça devient juste un
murmure que personne n'entend donc c'est
totalement inutile ou ça donne de
l'importance à des positions bruyante
mais minoritaire alors quoi vous vous
jeter dans la foule et que vous ajoutez
votre voix vous me fait qu'alimenter
cette spirale stérile et cette
rhétorique stérile donc se tait et
parfois le fait de l'acheter mais aussi
le fait d'un pragmatisme perd maintenant
est de rebondir sur un point par exemple
l'exemple du voleur nascar
il ya un double au début de l'année je
pense qu'on a commencé à parler du la
campagne du racisme systémique et tout
un bruit tout temps et tout un scandale
qui carrément kiki ac a répliqué qui a
éclaté sur le terme systémique et ce qui
a poussé des politiciens carrément breux
rétropédaler est carrément on veut plus
parler on veut plus parler de ce racisme
et systémique parce que par crainte que
sous la pression et je dirais surtout
médiatique et le problème d'une pression
populaire comme quoi on taxe la société
québécoise de racisme mais c'est la même
c'est les mêmes politiciens qui ont
commis ces mots là dans les champs puis
après ils se sont rendu compte que ça
marchait pas bien qu'ils ont essayé de
la lgv est et comment est ce qu'on fait
en tant que société pour éviter que les
parties si politique qui prennent ce
thème très important pour du procédé
tisme comment est ce qu'on fait c'est ce
que j'appelle les pyromanes
effectivement pour l'exemple du racisme
systémique est très très intéressant
parce que c'est un exemple typique de ce
qui arrive quand on ne s'écoute pas et
quand on tire trop vite et qu'on propose
des solutions ou un run aide avant
d'avoir bien poser le diagnostic
et c'est typique ce qui est arrivé c'est
que au québec et au canada en a on a une
diversité de formes de discrimination il
ya la discrimination indirecte ou la
discrimination systémique qui est qui
est un effet c'est à dire que sans
vouloir explicitement exclure des gens
il ya des pratiques des pratiques
installée depuis longtemps et qui exclut
des personnes minoritaires et il ya le
racisme bête et méchant le sale noir
salle ceci salle cela et il y à là dit
il ya dans la discrimination systémique
des baies par exemple les fameuses
personnes qui sont diplômés et qui ne
trouvent pas d'emploi donc les barrières
systémique à l'emploi et là les deux
côtés ont été ont été responsables les
deux pompiers pyromanes ont été
responsables du fait que cette réflexion
et cette consultation est avorté autant
le gouvernement et les politiciens qui
ont fait du millage mais qui n'avait pas
bien réfléchi et qui ont peur et qui ont
leur propre et d'aller parce qu'ils
avaient peur que la société d'accueil se
sentent en procès et les militants qui
trop pressé trop pressés de proposer une
solution en pause et afu diagnostic
ils se sont mis à voir du racisme
systémique là on n'y en avait pas
d'accord il ya une différence entre dire
il y a il n'y a pas la diversité n'est
pas assez représentées dans les médias
la diversité n'est pas assez
représentées dans la littérature pour
enfants etc
et dire je me fais trop poser la
question d'où tu viens
j'ai fait exprès aubert de vous poser la
question tout à l'heure d'où vous venez
et moi ce que je voulais savoir c'était
pas et je voulais savoir à ce que vous
êtes
stagiaire invité au québec auquel cas je
me disais donc est-ce qu'il connaît
vraiment la réalité québécoise je vais
faire attention à ne pas le pas de
proposer des exemples qui comprendra pas
mais si vous êtes québécois installé ici
je m'en fous d'où vous venez vous
comprenez donc donc dire à quelqu'un
d'où viens tu ce n'est pas du racisme
systémique qui étaient installés dans
notre langage c'est parfois juste une
curiosité bienveillante
alors voilà ce qui est arrivé avec le
racisme systémique c'est qu'on a très
rapidement poser un diagnostic de racine
systémique sur des situations qui ne
m'était pas résultat des courses tout a
été effacé et là où il ya du free
racisme et de la vraie discrimination
on n'en parlera pas malheureusement
malheureusement et bien mon dieu est en
jeu 1
c'est je ne voyais pas de cette façon
moi je moi je vois tu les choses très
simplement je toujours que me dit
toujours une solution d'ailleurs la
charge d'un problème que la j'ajouterai
le mot précipitation dans tout ça il ya
l'amour et à la fable la précipitation
se précipitent pour éteindre un incendie
on n'a pas vu que finalement on a raté
la fin va peut-être ailleurs millet pas
la précipitation je tenais à le dire il
ya déjà des gens qui n'ont pas lu mon
livre qui ont lu un article qui sont
déjà en train de me la iglesia ce que je
défends multiculturalisme alors qu'il ya
plein de pages dans mon ouvrage où
justement je pourfend le
multiculturalisme en disant que c'est
pas une solution
alors vous voyez il faut prendre le
temps d'écouter malheureusement mais si
c'est pas la solution
je sais que j'ai beaucoup de québécois
utilisent et utilise le terme ou le
concept d'interculturalisme culturalisme
comment vous vous naviguez à travers ça
vous oui l'interculturalisme c'est une
je dois dire que bon je suis spécialiste
à l'interculturel donc j'ai dû y croire
à un moment donné mais en tout cas le
défi livre comme ça mais la terre
culturalisme est une voie intéressante
dans la main
jour où elle est la conciliation des
deux de l'assimilationnisme à la
française et du multiculturalisme à la
canadienne
donc ce que j'appelle le vivre et
laisser vivre c'est le multiculturalisme
et vivre comme c'est à dire c'est
intégrer dans le champ de la citoyenneté
à tout le moins
parce que dans la vie privé chacun fait
ce qu'il veut mais le lait le noyau de
la pierre d'achoppement de
l'interculturalisme c'est qu'il faut il
ya un postulat de départ c'est qu'il
existe une une culture m'a dit
majoritaire la culture des francophones
et des anglophones et donc des deux
peuples fondateurs et que c'est autour
de cette culture majoritaire
francophones au québec parce que ce sont
les francophones et autour de cette
histoire commune à laquelle est venue se
greffer la révolution tranquille et à
laquelle ont participé aussi des vagues
d'immigration c'est autour de cette de
cette culture commune qu'on construit
une société compte d'abord qu'on fait le
débat interculturel et qu'on construit
une société interculturelle
mais il y a des objections il ya des
groupes qui est qui refuse qu'ils
récusent l'existence même d'un peuple
fondateur qui disent y'a papa il n'ya
pas de peuple fondateur
nous ne sommes qu'une vague une
succession de vagues migratoires qui a
commencé il ya 400 ans
donc cette majorité dont vous nous dites
qu'il faut partager les valeurs communes
c'est une vague d'immigration comme nous
sauf qu'elle est arrivée il ya 400 ans
et nous il ya quatre ans ou dix ans
seuls les peuples autochtones ont le
droit de dire qu'ils sont le sol autour
duquel cette société s'est construite
donc c'est la pierre d'achoppement de
l'interculturalisme c'est pour ça que ça
a beaucoup de difficulté à s'incarner
concrètement pour ma part je me dis même
si je suis prise plus tôt je penche
plutôt en faveur de l'interculturalisme
je me dis quand un modèle se heurte à de
telles résistances et que ça marche pas
dans le concret c'est pas il faut pas
s'acharner
alors il faut trouver il faut trouver
une autre un autre angle une autre
approche qui réunisse tous a le droit à
la différence et mais pour tous et
reconnaissance de l'existence d'une
culture quelque part qui a qui nous a
précédés cela dit je voulais quand même
préciser - ayant vécu au canada anglais
c'est ça que je voulais demande est
rejetée chez moi c'est d'aller canada
anglais c'est la même chose si la
question culturelle du français puis de
l'anglais c'est sa marque en différence
oui oui canada anglais mais ça se vit
différemment parce que je skie est ce
qui est différent au québec
c'est la question nationale c'est que le
lever c'est pas un pays donc dès lors
que dès lors que on a essayé d'ailleurs
ça a été la difficulté de la commission
taylor bouchard la commission des
leurres bouchard a essayé de dire bon il
ya un canada une culture canadienne il
ya le multiculturalisme dans lequel les
gens se retrouvent ou se retrouvent pas
mais bon et au québec
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être et ça
c'est tout de suite orpea à la question
très technique et très juridique la
citoyenneté symbolique la citoyenneté
québécoise est symbolique elle et pas
juridique
elle n'a pas d'existence juridique donc
c'est sûr que le québec a beaucoup plus
de difficultés dès qu'il parle de
culture commune parce qu'on a toutes une
toute une catégorie de la population qui
dit de quoi vous parlez et notre culture
commune c'est le canada à votre
passeport et canadiens et notre notre
nos valeurs communes c'est la charte des
droits et libertés
c'est une très très grande difficulté
c'est dans ce sens là que je parle de
majorité ça a été mal interprété ou
jeudi les québécois ont cette double
difficulté qu'ils sont en même temps une
majorité il majorité historique mais en
même temps une minorité dans un océan
anglophone donc les autres ne le
reconnaissent miller statut d' majorité
parce qu'ils leur disent de toute façon
les autochtones étaient là avant vous
miller statut de mis leur statut de
minorité parce qu'on leur dit de quoi
vous vous plaignez vous avez des
privilèges
donc c'est très très particulier et
nommer cette réalité là et cette
ambiguïté là ce n'est pas être un
méchant multiculturaliste qui dit aux
québécois vous n'existez pas et ce n'est
pas non plus
être gentil immigrants qui lèchent les
bottes des québécois en leur disant moi
je vous ai compris
ces puces c'est juste nos 1000 réalité
mais la réalité historique et juridique
je suis un fascinant vous vous écoutez
c'est que c'est encore mieux quand on
veut on la lit je pense que l'un d'entre
vous ou peut-être deux allez avoir la
chance aujourd'hui de lire le livre
ok ça dépend si vous êtes bon des quizz
ceux qui vont suivre
rachida on vous a critiqué pour ce
nouveau mot que vous avez inventé la
majorité c'est ça mais elle s'étend en
france et puis ici au québec a ction à
chaque fois qu'on a inventé un nouveau
monstre reprocher quelque chose c'est
sortir de des sentiers battus et
personnes aiment ça
écoutez fantastique merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et si
vous merci merci beaucoup
vous savez c'était vraiment vous ouvrez
les papas le seulement les yeux mais des
oreilles aujourd'hui fantastique merci
merci valeurs communes là pour certains
vous comment catholique non non je vous
pose la question sur ma porte fort
clarification spirituelle comme d'accord
très bien on en apprend des choses avec
nos invités donc c'était rachida azdouz
as 12 psychologue spécialiste des
relations interculturelles
on veut pas arrêter de l'atteindre non
très intéressante le temps file mais si
vous voulez on va maintenant procéder au
second jeu de la grosse boule de trading
notre affaire ça nous prend l'éclairage
tamisé à chaque fois il faut réagir plus
rapidement
il fait la job de 2 comme on dit
aujourd'hui ils vont tous trois et
messieurs qui fait la lumière
c'est comme dans le bon vieux temps
ok alors voici là de la deuxième
question notre jeu aujourd'hui je vais
garder ça simple parce que joubert vous
avez déjà 20 % 20 points il l'a
maintenant on joue pour tendre point
question très facile c'était la journée
internationale contre le racisme
mercredi hockey cela fait cinquante et
un ans que l'on célèbre la journée
internationale pour l'élimination de la
discrimination raciale sur quel
continent a eu lieu l'événement qui a
été l'élément déclencheur de cette
journée sur
continent quand tu nord américain mais
ça semble être le cas
voulez-vous au revoir réviser votre
réponse africain l'europe africain
africaine 30 points à zoubair jazy
faudra pas la vie sur ces jeux
rappelons ce que tu veux mais vous avez
déjà 50 points donc est le prochain jeu
le dernier ce sera pour 50 points
également présente et que vous gagnez si
je l'espère vous ça vous arrive pas
souvent là on en est très très rare
alors je n'en parle de se tourner les
scan id c'est la première fois qu'ils
viennent
c'est ça c'est comme le joueur de
billard ont fait cinq mois que tu as eu
lieu écoutez c'est en main assez sérieux
il ya une histoire c'était au jeu dès
janvier de l'an dernier cet attentat
dans une mosquée dans la ville de québec
six personnes ont perdu la vie et le fou
qui a fait ça qui a reconnu sa
culpabilité cette semaine on va voir les
images
les images ce jeune homme de 28 ans
aujourd'hui on en a parlé beaucoup dans
l'actualité québécoise parce que il ay
là ils avaient dit non je suis pas
coupable à cette semaine il a dit je
préfère dire oui je suis coupable pour
éviter dit-il à la famille si on regarde
la vidéo à voir les explications il
s'est exprimé c'est les vidéos 6 je
pense que cette vidéo si souillac on a
sauté une coupe d'envoi alors je vous
demande est super de lire ce que ce
jeune homme a dit alors voilà ce qu'ils
le savent à ça c'est des images si je
vais me souvenir son dos son nom très
québécois d'ailleurs bissonnette oui
tout à fait merci c'est déjà un bon
départ ne l'ont pas mis sahel voici
maintenant ce qu'il a dit lorsqu'il
s'était présenté en cour cette semaine
le voici ça vient oui j'aimerais
j'aimerais vous dire à vous monsieur le
juge et à tous à chaque minute de mon
existence je regrette amèrement ce que
j'ai vu ce que j'ai fait
lévy que j'ai détruite la peine et la
douleur immense que j'ai aimé poser en
tant que en pente de personnes attendent
de personnes sans oublier les membres de
ma propre famille j'ai honte de ce que
j'ai fait je ne sais je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'ai posé un geste insensé
comme ça encore aujourd'hui j'ai de la
misère à y croire malgré ce qui a été
dit a demandé à mon sujet je me suis ni
terroristes ni un islamophobe plutôt je
suis une personne qui a été emporté par
la peur par la pensée est négatif et par
une sorte de la de forme horrible de
désespoir alors voilà ça je dois vous
dire que il a causé beaucoup de remous
puis là on apprenait ce matin ses
sorties dans les nouvelles que il
apparemment il aurait pris des
médicaments contre la dépression
médicament qui serait à la source de
d'autres cas comme ça aux états unis
notamment où des gens sont devenus fous
et se sont mis à tuer d'autres personnes
donc bon c'est ça s'ajoute à cette
histoire très récente dans la ville
québécoise qui a marqué beaucoup nos
relations ici depuis que ça c'est
produit bien sûr il ya eu une réaction
très vive la part de tout le monde je
pense en se disant mais qu'est ce qu'on
va voir où on s'en va à l'arrêt ce genre
de situation la cipa alexandre est
alexandre bissonnette merci d'avoir une
belle mémoire et sa plus simple
j'attends encore alors je voulais vous
parler de ça en vous disant qu'il ya
toute une conversation qui a eu lieu
depuis un an et trois mois maintenant
entre les personnes de religion
musulmane
même les arabes par extension et puis
les autres citoyens ici au québec les
belles conversations et on a vu la
communauté s'ouvrir au reste des
québécois
il ya une scène s'est passée dans les
deux sens un peu ce que rachida disait
finalement que ça se fasse
la critique doit se faire dans les deux
sens et je vous propose sept extraits
d'entrevues réalisées cette semaine par
maryse jobin avec la présidente du
centre islamique de l'outaouais ça c'est
pas loin de la ville de la grande
capitale ottawa
c'est au québec elle s'appelle hague est
lagoon et elle affirme que la diversité
doit être notre force et non pas une
chose qui devrait nous désunir ou créer
le chaos donc
la diversité mans on va oublier de la
terre culturalisme le multiculturalisme
à part la diversité
on va écouter ça c'est donc notre vidéo
numéro 7 cette semaine notre vue de
marie est ravi donc on sait depuis ça
s'est passé on a personne ici à tandis
qu'on peut faire de mieux
la première des choses qui nous est de
nous évader c'est qu'ils n'ont pas eu
dans une poêle de mes connaissances au
lycée des gens rentraient la moquette
voir ce que c'est un sens oui
certainement qui on a un centre
communautaire dans lequel il se passe
plein d'activités et on nous avons
constaté une affluence considérable et
les gens nous ont remerciés je suis
veulent renouveler l'expérience
c'est qu'en fait tout aussi on donne des
cours d'arts à pour une en français une
en arabe au plus tôt il ya des gens
ayant de l'intérêt dans la culture
musulmane tenir général et
l'apprentissage de la langue arabe pour
différentes raisons donc en 1 simplement
et tout ce temps là pour le moment en
offre des cours d'arabe
on est rendus au niveau 2 il était de
mon devoir pour le niveau 1 et on va
essayer d'accommoder les gens et pour
donner il suffit pas d'ouvrir ses portes
seulement ils furent où il faut aussi
aller de l'avant
alors voilà pour la suite toute
l'entrevue qui dure 10 minutes vous
allez sur la page de tam-tam canada
cette semaine la page le tam tam canada
évidemment il s'agit de la page web de
la page les pages non c'est fini
alors voilà j'essaie de vous amener
maintenant vers je vais vous donner la
réponse de me poser la question hors
d'onde
oui mais cet événement en afrique qui a
suscité la création de leur descendre le
racisme c'est quoi au fait
évidemment voici la réponse c'est un 21
mars 1960 en afrique du sud
j'ai découvert ça cette semaine sa date
d'avant notre naissance donc des fois on
voit on aura quand on perd le fil de
l'histoire des fonds il manque des
éléments essentiels des analyses alors
ce jour là 21 mars 1960 en afrique du
sud il ya des citoyens qui manifestaient
autour des postes de police contre un
passeport intérieur les noirs était
obligé de posséder un nouveau passeport
intérieur
c'était une imposition de la part des
blancs qui étaient évidemment les sucs
avait le pouvoir et la police à un
moment s'est senti comme coincé et s'est
mis à tirer sur la foule et sa incident
qui a fait 69 morts 178 blessés pensez-y
là dans l'histoire on parle d'un bond de
ce qui s'est passé en inde quand les
britanniques ont tiré sur la foule dans
un stade ça c'est genre d'histoire qui
devrait être aussi autant connue moi je
ne connaissais pas je la portais ça
cette semaine
des fois c'est frappant c'est frappant
et peut-être que ça a été les éléments
qui a apporté le reste de la planète a
condamné l' app à l'origine de
l'apartheid c'est dans ce chantier
autour de la pierre en fait en afrique
du sud c'était vraiment les noyaux de
cette histoire de l'intolérance alors
c'est très c'est très normal que ça suce
que ce soit ça qui qui sait si c'est
regarder comme la journée pour se
rappeler de cette histoire des balises
comme ça qu'ils nous montrent jusqu'où
on doit pas aller et ça c'est produire
dit non ça c'est sûr qu'on peut pas il
faut arrêter un moment donné mais c'est
ce que je comprend pas ce qu'est on est
dans et 2018 pire des présidents qui
continue à faire ces gens trop ça
cette trempe il continua
à pousser là la foule a poussé les
jeunes pousser les limites au sujet des
immigrants déjà qu'ils sont port comme
lui quand il met puis ça ça fait mal
parce que nous on est des ses côtés là
on les regarde en bord dix ans mais ça
fait mal les gens ils commencent à
prendre des décisions à partir des skis
voir et ce qu'ils ont fait ça c'est
vraiment dommage parce que je pense que
dans ce qu'il y a au canada il ya des
lois contre les déclarations haineuses
je sais pas quel serait le critère qui
lui sera appliquée s'il devait être le
premier ministre du canada
mais je pense qu'il se ferait amassé
assez rapidement dans les cours de
justice ici ce serait beaucoup plus je
sais pas si nous on serait plutôt des
rares mais moi je me dis c'est quand
même des histoires assez sérieuse mais
l'impact de ces idées ou à la limite
xénophobe sur monsieur tout le monde
à force d'y voir et l'omniprésent
l'omniprésence de 2,30 et ses discours
et c'est parfois ces bêtises 24 sur 24
sur twitter 7 sur 7
sais tu vois cette présence médiatique
si tu essaies de consulter le meilleur
les les articles ou les chroniques
laissons-les qui sont les plus
populaires sur les médias tu vas trouver
plus que 50 % qui parlent de 30 et en
véhicules ont ce discours là même ceux
qui sont ne sont pas à force de taper
sur ce discours là comme je l'avais dit
à la limite xénophobe et très
identitaire ça devient les gens ils sont
souvent devenir très sensible à ce genre
de discours si vous le permettez on est
prêt pour une partie plaisir quand même
jour c'est un vendredi pascal n'est prêt
pour l'internet dernière manche
je réalise mon technicien pierre qui est
du côté du sang et qu'ils devaient
participer aussi au revoir vous auriez
pas le droit évidemment
techniquement parlant c'est pas possible
mais écoutez voici la question c'est
très simple parce que je pense que c'est
une des richesses qu'on a je rachète en
a parlé des couples mixtes que c'est
difficile dans un couple mixte pour les
enfants de ces couples a dénoncé
de leurs couleurs quoi c'est sûr ça ça
calme les choses
alors quel est le pourcentage
véritablement canada des couples mixtes
qu'elle sur le 100 %
combien y at il véritablement de couples
mixtes au canada aujourd'hui cuir au
dessous de 20% aux alentours de 10
quelque chose comme ça on veut que vous
soyez plus précis moins large mais à
moins que pour ça pour 24% -2 -2 10%
sociaux moins de 10 % et notre
technicien sonore 10,8 pour ça on a bien
je viens décoder 8 pour ça et bien
pierre du côté de la technique sonore
vous avez deux fois la bonne réponse
la bonne réponse et 4% c'est dommage
nous aurons vous aurait accordé 1 50%
avec le avec grand plaisir mais pas
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible
alors voulez savoir ce que vous gagnez
vivement vous avez 50 % ouais vous avez
50 % vous gagné tous les deux le prix de
participation cette semaine qu'ils se
trouvent
je me dire ça va reprendre de temps vous
avez trouvé ça très drôle là dans la
vidéo numéro deux vient la vidéo numéro
2 vous allez trouver votre parti pris de
participation tous les deux cette
semaine ça vous attend lorsqu'on je
retourne au bureau je sais la
présentation de livres
si tu lis donc je vous présente votre
prix de paris bat combat vous voulez
vous faire jouer la vidéo numéro de
hockey pour que tout le monde voit ce
que vous avez gagné c'est la preuve j'ai
deux copies du livre donc jeunes offrent
les deux copies ça vaut quand même
donc voilà le lit le livre vivre
ensemble n'est pas un rince bouche
d'accord merci 220 pages de
l'apprentissage
on voit ça va prendre un livre de chevet
voilà je sais que vous allez lire avec
impatiente
voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine
zoubair vous vous êtes dans le secteur
que là c'est souvent ouais ça m'arrive
d'être dans les parages comme d'accord
parce qu'on pourrait vous réinviter mais
tout dépend de vous oui oui
j'ai dix ans vous aviez la section
chinoise avant nous comme responsabilité
vous avez la section espagnole où c'est
leonardo qui s'en sert en fait on fait
moins thématique quelque chose qui ont
fait chacun de notre côté pour les pour
l'émission life 3 ordinateurs pour deux
personnes
c'est efficace mais très bien merci je
vous pose plus de questions c'est décidé
c'est pour ça cette semaine ici stéphane
parent avec joubert josy et leona